Consider the roadside ditch provided. Using the chart excerpt from the
Ashto roadside design guide, determine the steepest allowable force lobe in
units of vertical slash horizontal. So in this problem all we need to do is use
the Ashto chart provided to correctly identify the steepest allowable
force lobe in units of vertical slash horizontal. First we need to recognize
that force lobe is the first slope leading down from the roadway to the
bottom of the v-ditch and the back slope is the second slope leading back up to
the ground surface. So we can draw a line from the back slope given which is 1
colon 5 or 1 vertical unit to 5 horizontal units. Once we reach the edge of the
preferred channel cross section we can draw the line either up or down. The
problem asks for units of vertical slash horizontal. So let's draw this
line downward. As can be seen we land somewhere between 0.3 and 0.2.
Typically it makes sense to round to the more conservative slope. So let's pick
the smaller of the two numbers given. This would be less than the max allowable
foreslope according to the chart but rounding the other way would exceed our
limitations instead. You will notice that technically 1 colon 5 is the same
slope as 0.2. But the problem asks for units of v slash h so we will pick 0.2
instead. And that's all it takes to solve this problem.